hello that's my run
oh my god i love your impression
you might not be ready for this
me i was born ready close your eyes and
you just might think you're listening to
celine dion lee leonard hello
but no that's ariana grande doing her
best impression of the music icon it was
a real surprise during monday's episode
of the voice the grammy winner broke out
her best impression of celine after 17
year old xavier cornell performed his
cover of katy perry's teenage dream
[Applause]
[Music]
i thought that was a really beautiful
take on that song it almost sounded like
the song from the titanic like the
celine dion song at the end you did
coincidentally like the same run man i
sure hope you don't get sued for
stealing that lick from the titanic song
indiana hello that's my run
oh my god i love your impression
but this isn't the first time ari has
busted out her hidden talent it's the
most fun i've ever had in my whole life
back in 2015 during a stop by the
tonight show starring jimmy fallon she
showed off her celine skills singing the
weekend's hit track can't feel my face
in the canadian singer's voice
[Music]
i mean that's impressive oh thank you
the 3435 singer is clearly a fan of
celine and when the two attended the
same event back in 2016 e.t asked if
she'd ever do her impression for the
music legend everyone is asking me what
i'm gonna do when i see celine i think
it's so funny that everyone knows how
much i love her um no i'm just gonna be
like
hi
but back to the voice kelly clarkson
ultimately landed xavier after her
one-chair turn hi xavier hi kelly i'm so
stoked that i want to fight for you
i think you are going to be a dark horse
in this competition and in et's
exclusive sneak peek at the final night
of blind auditions san antonio texas
native erin hines takes the stage and
turns all four chairs
i love your voice you just sounded like
you knew what you wanted to do with the
song you went out there and executed it
beautifully so i got to tell you this
can't tell you how many times i'm saying
all of me at like weddings
the two even harmonized john legend's
2013 hit single
loves all of you
all
we'll just have to wait to see which
coach erin goes with but one thing is
for sure the competition this season is
tough especially with ariana joining the
show something kelly john and blake
shelton opened up to et about leading up
to the season 21 premiere she's a threat
she is hugely talented hugely successful
and has legions and legions of fans that
know how to use the internet and vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it coming in i was
prepared i came with in battle armor
i'm prepared to be turned down just
being new there's so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing
[Music]
you